let's talk about nucleophilic aromatic
substitution this is not your typical
reaction of aromatic compounds aromatic
compounds as we've seen before with
electrophilic aromatic substitution can
act as nucleophiles attacking an
electrophile and becoming substituted
however in certain cases nucleophiles
can actually attack the aromatic ring
let's look at an example in this example
we have this aryl chloride undergoing
substitution when treated with sodium
methoxide notice we have an electron
withdrawing group here this is going to
be critical to the mechanism and on this
side we have a leaving group
now the substitution pattern here is
important the leaving group needs to be
para or across from the electron
withdrawing group it can also have an
electron withdrawing group adjacent to
it or in the ortho position we need to
look at mechanistically why this works
and you might be tempted to draw an sn2
mechanism let's consider the sn2
mechanism for a second so our
nucleophile would have to come in a
backside attack to displace this
chloride now when we're looking at this
that means it would have to come
completely through the aromatic ring
which sterically is not possible so we'd
have to attack like this
and geometrically this just cannot occur
never do sn2 chemistry at an sp2 center
okay what about an sn1 mechanism for an
sn1 mechanism to occur this halide would
have to leave on its own now this Erol
cation is pretty high energy that
doesn't mean it's impossible to form we
see it form from aryl diazonium salts
and I have a video on that mechanism if
you're interested however hey lights are
not good enough leaving groups to
promote the formation of this aryl
cation so this is just a reaction that
cannot occur and before I throw away
these mechanisms and ask you to erase
them from your memory forever I want to
really point out sn2 is for tetrahedral
carbon and it does not work with vinyl
halides or aryl halides like we have
here then how does this mechanism occur
and why do we need electron withdrawing
groups this reaction actually occurs by
an addition elimination mechanism so our
first stage of this is adding in
methoxide and we have this extended
conjugated system going through the
entire electron withdrawing group so let
me show some arrow pushing that explains
why this can occur
first we get attack at the
carbon-bearing
the leaving group these electrons are
going to move over
and we can continue pushing all the way
through our nitro group
we'll get an intermediate that looks
like this my nitrogen here had four
bonds and so I had to add on that
positive charge and just added it back
on in this structure as well okay so
this is the addition step our methoxide
came in and utilizing this entire
conjugated system was able to add now if
we push electrons back up restoring
aromaticity we can kick out a leaving
group
and this gives our substituted product
now I showed this mechanism by pushing
electrons through the entire conjugated
system but if that's hard for you to see
I recommend drawing your mechanism to
arrows at a time and let's just do that
to break it down even a little bit more
and make sure we have our arrow pushing
correct so taking it to arrows at a time
first our nucleophile will attack here
and then we'll have to move these
electrons onto this carbon atom
this arrow pushing gives us this
compound now we can push electrons in
here making a double bond and take the
electrons from this double bond and push
them on to the carbon
that gives this resonance form and
finally still pushing two arrows at a
time we can make this a double bond and
put the negative charge on oxygen and
show how our nitro group is stabilizing
this charge just pushing two electrons
at a time that will give us this
resonance form I want to highlight this
resonance form here notice that we get
buildup of negative charge on this
carbon as well and so this explains why
an electron withdrawing group at the
ortho position - the leaving group is
also effective in promoting this
reaction we can stabilize an anion here
and notice we can stabilize an anion
here with our nitro group and we showed
all that resonance so that explains the
positioning of one or two electron
withdrawing groups on the ring let's
look at an example within ortho electron
withdrawing group to illustrate the
scope of this reaction a little more
here were reacting this Errol fluoride
with an ortho electron withdrawing group
with sodium cyanide and getting
replacement of the fluoride for cyanide
but you may be wondering why fluoride
can undergo this reaction fluorine is a
terrible leaving group in sn2 reactions
so how is this possible
well in the mechanism this step removes
aromaticity from the compound so this
makes this into something that is not
aromatic temporarily this is hard this
is the difficult step therefore that is
the rate determining step
now elimination of the leaving group is
fast it restores aromaticity in the
compound and is really favorable so
fluorines only role in the rate
determining step is being a very
electronegative element that creates a
great dipole here and makes this carbon
even more electrophilic there for
fluorine promotes this reaction very
well because of its electronegativity
and because it's poor leaving group
ability is not part of the rate
determining step this reaction actually
works great let's do a quick practice
problem to see if you've got this down
take a
look at these three substrates pause the
video if you need to and see if you can
work out which of these is most likely
to undergo nucleophilic aromatic
substitution okay so we're looking for
the substrate with an electron
withdrawing group the first one is no
good this nitrogen has a lone pair that
actually can donate electron density to
the ring by resonance this is not an
electron withdrawing group now here our
chlorine is going to make this position
more electrophilic due to its higher
electronegativity
but the bromide this is an inductive
electron withdrawing group so we do have
an electron withdrawing group here
however remember bromine also has lone
pairs and this can donate electron
density by resonance to the Ring so this
isn't the most awesome electron
withdrawing group since it just has the
inductive electron withdrawing effect
our winner is going to be the nitrile
here with the cyano group on it if we
draw up this structure even more we'll
see we have this extra conjugation so
when a nucleophile attacks we can
actually push electrons through this
entire conjugated system now if you're
having trouble figuring out which groups
are electron withdrawing and which
groups are electron donating and why I
highly recommend my video trick for
determining ewg versus EDG I hope that
you learned something and that you have
a great day today